يلتقي قاده الجيش الاوكراني ويامر بارسال
قوات اضافيه الى جبهه بخموت
مع اقتراب طهران من عتبه تخصيب اليورانيوم
بتسعين
رئيس الصين يتهم واشنطن بمحاوله تطويق
بلاده ووزير خارجيته
[موسيقى]
مدينه باغموت كان يقطنها 70 الف نسمه قبل
اشتداد المعارك
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
5400 اوكراني فقط لا يزالون في المدينه
الجنود الاوكرانيون المتحصنون في خنادق
مؤمل
الروس يحاصرون ضخمه من ثلاث جهات باستثناء
المحور الغربي
الجنود الروسي يتحسنون بخنادق بمحيط
المدينه لتجنب القصف الاوكراني
الرئيس الاوكراني اتفقت مع القاده
العسكريين على استمرار الدفاع عن ضخمه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ضخمت لها رمزيه لكن
سقوطها بيد روسيا لا يغير مجرى الحرب
هذا وندد رئيس الاوكراني بعمليه اعدام
لجندي الاوكراني على جبهه القتال الشرقيه
اوكرانيا ووصفه بالعمل الوحشي وتداولت
وسائل اعلام عالميه مشهد جندي اوكراني
اعزل وهو يردد عباره المجد لاوكرانيا قبل
ان يتم ارداؤه قتيلا برصاص جنود روس
في غضون ذلك يبدو ان الخلافه بين مجموعه
فاغنر والجيش الروسي لم ينتهي قائد
المجموعه
من الوصول الى مقر العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وحذر من ان اجبار فاجنر على
التراجع سيدفع الجبهه باكملها يا الانهيار
في ضخمه
خلف هذه الجبهه يتجدد توتر بين الجيش
الروسي وقوه فاغنر التي تطوق مدينه باخموت
الاوكرانيه بعد اسابيع من تقاذف الاتهامات
التي وصلت حد الشتائم والتخوين في جديد
توتر بين الجانبين يقولوا زعيم فاجنر
يفغيني ان الجيش الروسي منع ممثله من
الدخول الى مقر العمليات الخاصه الروسيه
الذي يدير العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
بريكوجين اكد الغاء تصريح ممثله ومنعه من
الوصول الى مقر العمليات مجددا حاجه قوته
الماسه لذخيره وان الخطوط الاماميه في
بخموت مهدده بالانهيار وفي حال انسحاب
فاغنر سيتاثر الجميع
فيما يشبه التسابق بين
الكريمار الانتصار المحتمل في باخموت
مرارا حتى وصل الامر الى المطالبه بتعيينه
وزير للدفاع عبر منصات غير رسميه مواليه
له
قبل بزيارتين لوزير الدفاع الروسي
الى الجبهات احداها الى ماريوبول والثانيه
الى مركز قياده على الجبهه في دونيتسكو
جدا سحبت شركه فان الجبهه ستنهار باكملها
المقاتلون يسالونني لماذا التاخير في
امدادات الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو
وايضا لماذا لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر
جدد
الكريميلين ووفقا
كان وعد بتسليمه اسلحه منذ 23 من فبراير
الفائته لم يتسلم شيئا حتى اللحظه تاخير
فسره باحد الامرين
برقراطيه او خيانه
ونشر مشاهدين الى هذا الخبر عاجل نقلا عن
وكاله رايترز وزير الدفاع الامريكي يصل
الى العراق في زياره غير معلنه بالعوده
الى سياق نشاطنا رفع الاوكرانيون الذين
يعيشون قرب خطوط النار رفعوا نداءات لوقف
الحرب التي دمرت كل ما يملكون
والسلامه في العالم باسره اتمنى ان لا
تكون هناك حرب اريد للناس ان يعيشوا حياه
طيبه وان يعيشوا بسلام لا اعرف ماذا اقول
لا اريد ان يموت ازواجنا وابناؤنا
منذ اندلاع الحرب تم هدم كل مبنى تقريبا
دمرت العديد من المنازل واحرقت العديد من
المنازل غادر الكثير من الناس لكن بقي
الكثيرون هنا لانها ارضهم وطنهم الام هناك
اناس لا يستطيعون المغادره
بحث وزير الخارج السعوديه الامير فيصل
بفرحان مع نظيره البريطاني عدد من القضايا
من بينها الازمه بين روسيا اوكرانيا وذكرت
وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان الوزيرين ناقش
ايضا خلال لقائهما في لندن المستجدات على
الساحتين الاقليميه والدوليه والجهود
المبذوله بشانها الى جانب سبل تعزيز
الشراكه بين البلدين في كافه المجالات
دعا رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي
للطاقه الذريه الى الموافقه على قرار يدين
ايران بسبب عدم تعاون الطيران واعتبر من
انجاز اتفاق طهران مع الوكاله على زياده
مراقبه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
للمنشات النوويه الايرانيه لا يرقى الى
مستوى معالجه خطوات ايران الاستفزازيه
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس
الشيوخ قال انه يجب على المجتمع الدولي
الرد على استمرار النظام الايراني في
تخصيب المواد النوويه الى مستويات قياسيه
تقترب من عتبه 90%
وكانت وكاله فرانز نقلت عن دبلوماسيين ان
مجلس محافظين وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
لن يصدر قرارا جديدا بشان ايران هذا
الاسبوع في فيينا على الرغم من التصعيد
بشان برنامجها النووي وذلك بعد تفاهمات
ملموسه توصل اليها المدير العامل وكاله
روسي في نهايه الاسبوع الماضي في طهران
وقال ثلاثه دبلوماسيين غربيين على هامش
اجتماعات اليوم الاول من الاجتماع فيينا
حيث مقر الوكاله الدوريه للطاقه الذريه
قالوا انه لن يكون هناك قرار
بعد امين وعمل وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفائيل روسي من طهران متفائلا
بتعاون بناء مع ايران رغم التناقض في
تفسيره للاتفاق الذي توصل اليه هناك مع
التفسير الايراني ولكن نبره غروسيا
المتفائله يبدو انها كافيه هذه المره
لتجنيب ايران اي قرار جديد ضدها داخل مجلس
المحافظين وتحدث جروسي في مؤتمر صحفي في
فيينا عن الاتفاق مع المسؤولين الايرانيين
على تعاون في تحقيق الوكاله حول المواقع
النوويه السريه وحول تفسير العثور على اثر
يورانيوم مخصب في منشاه فوردو بنسبه
84%
كنا ندور في حلقه مفرغه والان انطباعي بان
هناك فرصه للابتعاد عن هذه الحلقه ونرى
حقا تقدما في هذه النقاط وخاصه في منشاه
فوردو التي ستخضع لمراقبه المفتشين
المحافظين او حتى اقرب من خلال الدعوه
للاجتماع طارق اذا لزمل امر راغده بهنام
العربيه فينا
وفيما يتصل بقضيه تسميم فتيات ايرانيات
طالب البيت الابيض باجراء تحقيق مستقل
لمصداقيه وبمراقبه المسؤولين عن تصميم
الطالبات مشيرا الى ان هذه القضيه يمكن ان
تكون ضمن صلاحيات بعثه الامم المتحده
الدوليه المستقله لتقصي الحقائق في ايران
في حال ثبت ان عمليات تسنيم هذه على صله
بالمشاركه في الاحتجاجات كما اشار بيان
البيت الابيض الى ان تسميم الفتيات في
المدارس الايرانيه لمجرد لمجرد مطالبتهن
بالتعليم امر مخزن
مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
هجوم الاسرائيلي يخرج مطار حلب في سوريا
من الخدمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نجد الرئيس
الصيني خلال جلسه برلمانيه بحملت بحمله
غربيه تقودها الولايات المتحده لتطويق
بلاده واحتوائها وقمعها وذلك بحسب ما نقلت
وسائل اعلام الحكوميه مساء الاثنين قبل
ذلك قال وزير خارجيه الصيني شين جانج في
مؤتمر صحفي ان بلاده ستدافع بحازم عن
سياده البلاد وترفض العقوبات الاحاديه
محذرا واشنطن من ان مساله تايوان خط احمر
بنسبه لا ينبغي تجاوزه واتهم الاداره
الامريكيه بقياده حمله غربيه لشيطنه الصين
عبر العالم المسؤول الصيني اكد في السياق
ذاتها ان بلاده ستواصل الطباعه سياسه
خارجيه مستقله للسلام وستواصل تنفيذ
استراتيجيه الانفتاح وتبادل المنافع
[موسيقى]
وهذه مشاهدين الصور المباشره من البرلمان
الصيني بحضور الرئيس الصيني
وكما نشاهد على
الشاشه ايضا وزير خارجيه الصينيه يقول ان
واشنطن تقود حمله غربيه
هذه مشاهدنا الجلسه تاتي في خضم التوترات
الكبيره بين الصين
ودول الغربيه بما فيها الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا بفعل بسبب
اوكرانيا وبسبب دعم روسيا وبسب ايضا ملف
تايوان الذي يزيد من تعقيد العلاقات بين
الولايات المتحده والصين
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان العربي
بان مطار حلب ومحيطه وتم استهدافهما
بثلاثه صواريخ فيما تشير المعلومات
الاوليه الى ان الاضرار في مطار حلب ليست
جسيمه وكان اعلام النظام السوري قد اعلن
تعرض مطار العسكري وحلب الدولي لغارات
اسرائيليه من جهه البحر المتوسط غربيه
اللاذقيه ما ادى الى حدوث اضرار ماديه في
مطار حلب الدولي وخروجه عن الخدمه تلفزيون
والنظام السوري ذكر ان انفجارات متتاليه
سمع صداها في محافظات حلب وادلب واللاذقيه
كانت ناجمه عن غارات جويه اسرائيليه
استهدفت نقاطا عسكريه في محيط مطاري حلب
الدوري ومطار النيرب العسكري
اعلن الناطق باسم وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه
احمد الصحاف ان وزيره خارجيه المانيا
انلينا بيربوكه تزور بغداد اليوم الثلاثاء
وستلتقي المسؤوله الالمانيه خلال الزياره
برئيس مجلس الوزراء محمد شيعه السوداني
ونائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
فؤاد حسين لبحث الملفات الثنائيه
اعلنت سته احزاب معارضه تركيه ترشيح كمالك
منافسا لرجب طيب اردوغان في انتخابات
الرئاسه في مايو المقبل وخلال اعلان ترشحه
للرئاسه قالت لتجد زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري انه اتفق مع احزاب المعارضه
الاخرى على العوده للنظام البرلماني واكدت
المعارضه التركيه في بيان انها تعتزم
الغاء جميع المجالس السياسيه الرئاسيه
وتعزيز البرلمانيه بشكل كبير في البلاد في
حال فوزها في الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه باصابه سته فلسطينيين
في بلده حوار جراء تجدد المواجهه بين
فلسطينيين ومستوطنين اسرائيليين واوضح
مراسلنا ان المستوطنين للاسرائيليين
هاجموا منازل ومتاجر في حواره وهدد السكان
واشار مراسل العربي الى ان المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين حطموا عاده من السيارات في
البلده خلال مسيره راقصه احتجاجا بما يسمى
عيد المساخر لدى اليهود
[موسيقى]
الحكومه البريطانيه اليوم الثلاثاء الى
تقديم مشروع للتعامل مع القوارب الصغير
التي تدخل البلاد عبر القناه الانجليزيه
المشروع الذي يواجه انتقادات داخل حزب
المحافظين الحاكم والمعارضه قد يفتي الى
بل يفضي الى منع المهاجرين غير القانونيين
من اللجوء الى بريطانيا المزيد في هذا
التقرير مع الزميله عروب عبد الحق
رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه مصمم على وضع حد
لازمه اللاجئين غير الشرعيين في بريطانيا
حيث من المتوقع ان تصدر حكومه حزب
المحافظين مشروع قانون يوضح كيفيه التعامل
مع القوارب غير الشرعيه التي تمر عبر
القناه الانجليزيه ولكن هناك العديد من
الانتقادات التي تواجه مشروع القانون هذا
الذي يوصف بانه قاسي حتى قبل صدوره مثلا
من داخل حزب المحافظين الذين يرون بان
الشوناك ربما يغامر بمنحه وعودا كبيره دون
الالتفات الى الجانب الانساني لطالبي
اللجوء كما انهم يعتبرون ان مشروع القانون
هذا لن ينجح دون مشاركه فعاله وجديه من
فرنسا حزب المعارضين حزب العمال يرى بان
مشروع القانون هذا غير قابل للتطبيق وبانه
ربما تكتيك سياسي قبيل انتخابات مايو 2024
طبعا ازمه اللاجئين غير الشرعيين ازمه
ليست جديده على بريطانيا
ولكن المعطيات السياسيه هي التي تغيرت
هناك حكومه جديده تريد اثبات نفسها هناك
اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين الذين وصلوا الى
بريطانيا خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
ولكن الاهم ربما ان بريطانيا تريد ان تثبت
انها قادره على السيطره على حدودها رغم
وعيوبه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
والى فرنسا مشاهدينا حيث توقفت امدادات
المشتقات النفطيه في عموم البلاد صباح
اليوم وفق ما اعلنت قناه الفرنسيه في وقت
اغلق غاضبون محطه شوز النوويه في منطقه
اردان شرق فرنسا يحدث هذا في وقت تستعد
البلاد اليوم لتحرك شعبي ونقابي واسع
النطاق احتجاجا على مشروع قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد والذي يتضمن رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما بدلا من 62 عاما هذا هو يعد
التحرك الشعبي المرتقب اليوم امتدادا
لتحركات سابقه اخرى حدثت خلال الشهرين
الماضيين وياتي تحت شعار اغلاق فرنسا
ويمهد الطريقه امام بدايه اضراب مفتوح
يمتد لايام عده
في نهايه النشر مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز
العناوين
سكي يلتقي بقاده الجيش الاوكراني ويامر
بارسال قوات اضافيه الى جبهه
مع اقتراب طهران من عتبه تخصيب اليورانيوم
بتسعين في المئه دعوات بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي لردع ايران
رئيس الصين يتهم واشنطن بمحاوله تطويق
بلاده ووزير خارجيته يحذر امريكا من نيران
تايوان
نهايه هذه النشر المشاهدين كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]